People sometimes ask what does it all
mean?
And that's a very hard question to
address because it's not clear what an
answer would look like.
A question that I found much more
fruitful that I think one can address
sensitively is does the world and body
beautiful ideas.
That's a question we can address on both
sides.
What is the world and what is beauty?
What is the world of course is the kind
of question that science addresses.
What is beauty is something that art and
philosophy and a human culture
addresses.
And so we can look at the record of what
people have found beautiful,
what they were hoping for in their
understanding of the world,
with what the remarkable understanding
of the world we've achieved in recent
years looks like.
And we can therefore a frame,
a meaningful discussion and a meaningful
question,
a meaningful meditation on the issue of
does the world embodied beautiful ideas.
Some of the things that people,
uh,
at the beginning of this adventure we're
hoping for and uh,
had in their visions was in [inaudible]
the idea that the world embodies
harmonies.
That he talked about a music of the
spheres.
Plato,
uh,
had a theory of Adam's based on the so
called Platonic solids,
which are very symmetric objects.
They were hoping that our sense of
harmony,
so somehow agreed with what nature,
uh,
likes to use and her construction of the
world.
And more specifically with,
uh,
with Plato and the platonic solids,
the idea that ideas that symmetry and
mathematical perfection,
uh,
provide the building principals that the
world embodies
those themes which,
uh,
Pythagoras and Plato articulated very
well in the early days,
uh,
have inspired people for centuries,
prior to the modern times when we found
that nature does in fact use those
ideas.
Visual imagery is very important to our
understanding of the world because
humans are intensely visual creatures.
Uh,
depending on how you do the accounting
between 20 and 50% of our brain is
devoted to processing visual information
and we have some very impressive
capabilities in that direction we face
in interpreting the world a very
challenging problem that we're good at
solving.
We're so good at it.
With that,
we don't consciously realize how
difficult it is.
That's the problem of taking the
electromagnetic radiation,
the light that impinges on our retina,
giving a two dimensional image that's
all scrambled and interpreting that as a
three worlds of three dimensional
objects moving around in three
dimensional space.
That's a very difficult,
in fact,
impossible mathematical problem.
But we have many sophisticated tricks,
uh,
and rules of thumb plus a systematic,
although unconscious knowledge of
projective geometry so that we can
recognize that the same thing seen from
different positions is,
is this represents the same object.
These were,
uh,
when they were made conscious as a
geometric theorems and discoveries,
astonishing achievements that,
uh,
when Brunelleschi discovered the science
of perspective.
And in 1420 help kicked off kickoff the
glorious,
uh,
episode of the Italian Renaissance and
has been,
uh,
a foundation of art ever since.